six one seven eight three zero 4750 pats
having a quiet quite a ball over there
today let's go to the caller from the
845 area code caller from 8:45 who's
there you can jump right into your
question all right hey it's a mark
benjamin from Clarkstown go ahead mom
once I called in about economics thank
you for one thank you for the suggestion
I'm actively listening to it on audio
great book websites and - I have more
questions on information gathering
because I saw your podcast with destiny
yes even bonell known as yestiny in the
live in the gaming world of course yeah
I in general
suck it look like I don't understand
specifics or nothing that enough about
statistics to trust another source until
I get my head around it okay like you
know a good idea so what I normally do
is search out a bunch of YouTube YouTube
channels try to get a general gist of
both if not all sides of the issue and
then come to a general understanding of
what's happening okay I try to learn
stuff through the same method so look
there's like an economic thing but look
up geopolitical or geo XI teachable
podcast on what's happening and how
metals work and how crypto works and how
all that crap works sure how's the best
way to learn statistics either in that
manner or how to try to you know fact
chase back um back check on on you know
on just like slowly learn how to get
used to that yeah yeah yeah very good I
think is a really good question here's
what I would do I would start with and I
hate that I'm just not a hundred percent
sure if this is the name of the book but
I think it's a book from the 40s I
believe called line would statistics or
something like that and that will give
you a very basic understanding of some
of the methods that are often used
including deliberate confusion or hand
picking of mean median or mode sort of
ignoring of baseline and base rates
truncating of y-axes on graphs like
it'll give you an initial understanding
I think it's called lying with
statistics although double-check it it's
an old book probably about 80 or 100
pages very little book all right then
real quick one more time the book is I
think it's called lying with statistics
all right
thank you how do I know then great day
okay all right well listen I had a I
could have gone into a whole thing but I
got he just wants listen do step one
after your after you read the book call
me back what a day what a day